I just came back from vacationing in
Italy which or as they say over there a
vacationing in it literally I don't
speak any Italian that's how we survived
the whole time it really works it
where's the restaurant came home from
the trip and one of our cats died yeah
it's all right we had three so two more
to go
no we love the cats we're kind of people
we love the cats we love them but we
babysat a I think that's what you call
it when you we dogs sat for a dog
babysat it and my daughter's hung out
with a dog for the first time they're
like oh this is pretty amazing like you
like it and it loves you back and
doesn't try and scratch my sister's eye
out can we get one of these I was like
yes you can get one of those I will get
you a dog as soon as the cats pass I'll
get you a dog and the next day BAM one
down yeah No
no explanation no everyone very
hush-hush about it no one's even not
even it's here I didn't even see it here
kids were just walking around like
what's a collie like I've been hanging
out with them all summer so I've been
very lazy it's been a lazy summer you
know whenever I'm hanging out like that
I'm just kind of lazy I realize how
great am I really gonna be on the planet
you know I mean like people really
changed the world they don't hang out in
the summer like Edison these people are
built differently they're just different
right they don't need sleep
no sleep Edison two three hours a night
I need a lot of sleep I can't be that
successful I need sleep sometimes I wake
up in the morning my first thought is I
don't think I'm gonna get a nap today
I haven't even sat up I don't even know
if I'm tired I don't know what happened
I was like I don't think it's gonna
happen so what does it mean it means
that uh you know it's just a genetic
thing I'm just locked into my ancestors
well I come from a long line of Nappers
I do my whole childhood was waking up
adults to ask them stuff they would just
lay around the living room like a pile
of sea lions
like dad dad dad can I go to Keith's
house
grandma I gotta go he's aspirin
she moved her whiskers I think it's a
yes so what does it mean ultimately I'm
a little lazy I'm not gonna be part of
the super rich that's what it comes down
to I'm not gonna be part of the super
rich it was never really a goal of mine
but to be honest I always figured it's
probably gonna happen I'll just hang out
and I did the math like a month ago I'm
like I don't think this is gonna happen
and it was never a goal of mine it
really isn't I could live a poet's life
I don't need a lot of money I really
don't I can give all my stuff away I can
move all the time but I do not leave it
alone I'm married and I have two
children and they are greedy capitalist
pigs
more and more more when I want food with
every meal
so no I'm not gonna be part of the
super-rich and I have news for you
you're not either they don't do this and
come out on a hundred degree day they
ascend to Burbank to hang out with candy
they do different things they don't have
a summer they summer they summer yeah
yeah they summer I don't summer you
summer no summer happens and I deal with
it they buy all whites a whole white
wardrobe on Memorial Day to go summer I
can't wear white I what a white shirt
last summer I sweat through it in 20
minutes it looked like I was smuggling
turkey gravy under my armpit
I should have thrown it out I should
have thrown it out I spent 20 bucks for
it at Old Navy I'm gonna wear it I just
put my arms in the rest of the season
that we don't summer we don't wear all
white my family doesn't have parties in
the middle of a wheat field like the
super-rich we don't have a dining room
table in the middle of a field where
food just falls from the heavens and
everyone's beautiful and the dad stands
up and quote Shakespeare and everybody
laughs cuz they get it family we go to
my sister's crummy picnic table we eat
egg salad sandwiches and we push grandma
on the kiddie pool and her tip pops out
that's what we laugh at that's what we
get
oh grandma your Titov has Papa stout
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography